Gabriel Attal,
the oldest youngest,
1st Minister of the 5th Republic,
has made new announcements about the policies
antisocial government.
Not,
they are brutal.
First on unemployment insurance,
the previous one is barely in place,
1 news is already announced for more
Reduce the rights of unemployed people.
Stigmatizing the unemployed,
the government
seeks to mount those who work
against the so-called profiteers.
The goal is to reduce the duration of compensation
of several months
are upright
and increase working hours
necessary to benefit from the benefits.
But to lower unemployment rights as it wants in Tal,
is to new homes into misery
in more than 1,000,000 people
who already live below the poverty line.
At the same time,
the Macronists in the face
employer contribution relief
under the pretext of encouraging an increase in low wages.
Currently,
none of these measures
has never been effective
on fixed assets or wage increases.
Cent-quarante-cinq-milliards euros in profile
last for the case,
200 billion in public aid given to companies,
80 billion that escape in tax evasion.
Money,
there are some,
and many in the coffers of the employer.
But when Attal announces it wants to reduce the deficit
from 5.5% of GDP to less than
3% bydeux-mille-vingt-sept,
it is by taking from the budgets of the departments,
by saving services
and by appropriating our social contributions.
This government really believes us.
Idiots,
especially when they claim to want to
better prevention of accidents at work
while destroying
the same labor code
and by eliminating the positions
of those who enforce it.
same every day
it is at -2 people who die because of the
work in France.
It is anti-social policy
which is accompanied by discourse and measurement
always more racist and reactionary.
We could make the extreme right go up,
the latter is at the highest
in the voting intentions in the next elections
European elections. More than ever,
it is necessary to unite our social camp,
to build 1 combat left
in the face of the rise of reactionaries and authoritarians,
unitaries and revolutionaries.
With others,
the npa will continue to carry this orientation
in the street as well as in the ballot box.